the bush here in northern kenya has
become
almost a desert the iwasu-niyero river
reduced to little more than a trickle
for years now the area
has had far too little rain
shepherd abdiabkula keeps his goats
close to the water
at least there's something for the
animals to graze on here
and he never strays far from his village
these days we fear for our safety
our neighbors the samburu community keep
attacking us
they kill and steal our livestock
to help de-escalate the conflicts habiba
tadicha
often reaches out to the shepherds along
the river she used to head the local
nature conservancy
and is well known in the region disputes
over water and grazing land
have become frequent here she negotiates
with shepherds in this area of bellico
bulesa
while other women are in dialogue with
nearby communities
we have many meetings these meetings
especially like bilikobules i'm leading
like sarah there is a lady called
pauline who is leading
so even though because we are mother
and we know the disadvantages and
advantages of the
conflict so we decide to sit with our
young ones those who are leading in
conflict
our husbands and that's what makes this
unusual
women are taking the lead and making a
difference
the kenyan constitution upholds gender
equality
but in practice it's still the exception
the kenyan branch of the environmental
group tnc
is led by munira angonge she says kenya
needs more women leaders like habiba
tadicha
they're actually raising their voices
making decisions
on how their conservancies can be
managed especially for example if
there's a conservancy that
has tourism facilities and they get
conservation fees
there's the issue of sharing of those
proceeds between the operations of the
conservancy
and a percentage goes back to the
communities so that they can you know
invest in education health facilities
and others the tnc
runs 39 major conservancies in kenya it
also finances the one
in habiba toda's the conservancies
protect nature
offer job prospects and encourage women
to play a greater role in society
habiba tadicha benefited from the
conservancy and is now helping others
she and other women in her village have
built a culture center
[Music]
they did a lot of the work themselves
the women rent out the hall and the
lodges to visitors and local people
which brings in money
that's allowed them to set up a savings
club here the women give out loans to
each other
using income from the culture center
subsidies from ngos
as well as members own savings
leads the club she's given loans of 250
dollars to more than a hundred women
mostly to finance small business
ventures
dani roba got a loan from the savings
club to invest
in an electric motor for her corn mill
now she can earn more money
like so many here she's benefited from
the nature conservancy
melania in the beginning the local
community here was opposed to the
establishment of a conservancy
but habiba lobbied for it so that women
could benefit
she's very brave one time she was even
shot at
but she wasn't intimidated and just
carried on with her work
we're very happy now
tadicha doesn't want to talk about the
threats she's received
she'd rather focus on being a role model
for the next generation
at the local school she encourages
children not to give up
even when they face opposition
girls don't allow yourselves to be left
behind
and don't be shy all the time during her
time as head of the local nature
conservancy
habiba tadica secured funding for two
more classrooms here
today she's part of the council of
elders and has arranged financial help
for children from poorer families
to attend school those who have
prospects for the future she says
are less likely to engage in conflict
education is the best thing in our life
in everybody's life because
illiteracy
illiteracy to make stuff even not to
uplift our standards
for one
getting education you have you
you get jobs earning some salaries
uplifting your standard and even
additional of education
to everything is important if not
education
i myself i cannot be a leader of my
community
she loves her work but is often rushed
off her feet
she has three children and also cares
for her sick husband
then she has two small shops that she
opened with loans
from the savings club thankfully her
eldest daughter is able to help out
habiba tadicha hopes her daughter will
follow in her footsteps
and she certainly seems to have
inherited her mother's passion for
leadership
she already leads the local youth group
you